[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera
mi piace restituire una testimonianza
personale privata di un impegno etico
estetico Io negli anni 80
avevo mi era morto mio padre avevo
ereditato un'impresa di appalti pubblici
e in quel momento parliamo degli anni 80
era una Sicilia
dell'epoca abbastanza conflittuale
e io ho scelto
ho sentito parlare stasera sempre della
parola del tema anche della serata del
coraggio
Il coraggio e la coerenza e la coerenza
di una vita e la coerenza anche di
testimonianze ognuno di noi possiamo
portare come valore di differenza
una differenza che non vuole essere
omologata una differenza che non vuole
essere neanche riconosciuta a volte noi
aspiriamo anche al riconoscimento
il riconoscimento è la fabulazione
dell'ego più potente che noi possiamo
subire vogliamo essere riconosciuti e io
ho scelto invece sempre una via eretica
Ecco di scegliere quel valore di
differenza che ha trovato nel dono la
bellezza io non ho pagato mafia
non mi sono sedute tavoli negli appalti
pubblici ho chiuso l'azienda degli
appalti pubblici negli anni 80 ci
dicevano che per essere cittadini
bisogna essere Antimafia Ecco ho visto
vedo tanti giovani presenti in questa
contemporaneità quando sentite la parola
Antioco contro non paga paga sempre il
per
costruisce per fare la differenza e
avere Donato aver scelto di donare
bellezza al mio territorio fra Santo
Stefano di Camastra e Castel di Tusa
sono Otto piccoli comuni
che grazie al dono dell'arte che ho
fatto di queste grandi opere monumentali
che hanno segnato tutto il territorio
restituendo una ricucitura dell'anima
queste opere oltre avere un valore
estetico Sono delle grandi sculture non
so se qua riesco Questa è la scultura di
consagra che la prima opera della
Fiumara erano addossato in bianco e nero
che proprio era la prima opera che avevo
dedicato alla scomparsa di mio padre e
quando la mafia il sistema politico
l'ignoranza l'arroganza Ecco reggi a
questa mia posizione etica e
naturalmente utilizzando tutti i
linguaggi banali del male se parliamo di
mafia parliamo di attentati o che magari
ti ammazzano E allora ammazzavano negli
anni 80 se parliamo dello Stato
parliamo anche di quella burocrazia che
trovando nel comma nel comma b un atto
di abusivismo Ecco tutte le opere della
Fiumara Oltre agli attentati di mafia
sono state perseguite dallo stato al
quale io avevo Donato tutto il
patrimonio questa era la prima scultura
di consagra e le opere sono state tutte
incriminate di occupazione di suolo
pubblico Questa è la grande finestra sul
mare e località festa
quell'artista
ha scelto la rinuncia da una festa erano
dei più grandi pittori italiani e Qui
invece l'artista ha restituito la
visione della Bellezza attraverso la
cornice non dipinge la tela Ma lascia
alla visione di ognuno con la
possibilità di sentirci opera e tutte
queste opere Questo è il grande
labirinto di Arianna a Castel di Lucio
che è un chilometro dove anche qui
entrando da una porta di una grande
madre si arriva al centro verso il
centro il mostro il Minotauro è sempre
il nostro ego e quindi rimettendoci da
noi stessi Ecco ci può essere una
rigenerazione anche di quell'essere
bellezza e questo labirinto restituisce
tutto questa è la grande piramide di
Mauro staccioli questo è una delle
ultime opere che ho realizzato nel
territorio è una piramide di 30 metri in
cima alla montagna in corten e anche lei
la piramide restituisce la visione di
levare lo sguardo verso l'alto ma in
questo momento anche con le tecnologie
con i telefonini camminiamo sempre con
lo sguardo verso il basso Ecco questi
archetipi una piramide in cima alla
montagna sicuramente educa alla visione
della bellezza e quest'opera di un
grande maestro Mauro staccioli ha
segnato il territorio un faro di luce e
ogni anno al 21 giugno facevamo il rito
della luce ai piedi della piramide
Questa è la scultura di Paolo
schiavocampo Ecco tutte queste opere
hanno reso famoso il territorio nel
mondo
il territorio della Fiumara d'Asti è
diventato una meta internazionale e
quando si parla sempre
dell'abbandono dei piccoli Borghi delle
nuove generazioni che se ne vanno ecco
quando ci sono politiche con la p
maiuscola e quella culturale dell'Arte è
una politica di quella devozione alla
bellezza che ha vinto nel territorio non
vincono le sagre che i sindaci ancora
oggi organizzano vince la cultura dice
la politica culturale oggi la Fiumana
della Valle dell'alessa 10 Comuni sono
famosi nel mondo per un'identità
culturale per un impegno civile per una
coerenza che trovo ancora il senso oggi
nell'educazione alla bellezza e queste
opere ancora continuano come anche
l'albergo
anche ho fatto il museo albergo un'altra
agenzia educativa alla bellezza ha preso
un vecchio albergo 40 anni fa e ho
consegnato le stanze a tutti gli artisti
questa questa è una delle opere più
belle della Fiumara che la stanza di
Barca d'Oro ed è un'opera più grande
maestro nagasaua che l'avevamo fatta
perché avesse la vita di un giorno
un'opera che rinunciava alla visione al
consumo e lo stesso giorno in cui
l'abbiamo creata questa stanza è dentro
la montagna l'abbiamo chiusa con un
testamento spirituale per 100 anni Ecco
la bellezza rinuncia anche al consumo
della sua fruizione per consegnarsi allo
spazio tempo e nella sua dimensione
innocente e quest'opera farà piacere
adesso
prossimamente invece di riaprirla quindi
è un'occasione stasera pubblica per
comunicarlo perché è un'opera che
consegnava la visione dell'invisibile ma
forse oggi in questa contemporaneità
necessita di una nuova sua vita di un
nuovo
comunicare anche alle nuove generazioni
Questa è la caserma Carabinieri avevo
ricevuto uno dei tanti attentati di
mafia e io ho risposto ai mafiosi
costruendo facendo diventare
trasformando un prestito dello Stato
come la caserma Carabinieri e un'opera
d'arte qui Piero D'Orazio un mio grande
amico all'epoca
mi diede il progetto per poter
trasformare anche una caserma in quella
bellezza di essere arte poi L'albergo
con tutte le stanze hanno questo è
Librino
Ecco questa è l'albergo Questa è stata
un altro modo contemporaneo di educare
alla bellezza attraverso la fruizione di
una camera d'albergo l'artista crea lo
spazio chi entra in Queste stanze non
guarda più il quadro non guarda più la
scultura ma diventa opera ecco
restituirò Ognuno di noi quella
possibilità di sentirci opera Ecco
questo è un grande
arrivato il momento anche di
condivisione col pubblico perché non è
il museo d'arte contemporanea che noi
abbiamo visto negli anni 90 2000 e oggi
purtroppo chiudersi perché poi questi
contemporaneo non potessero mai un museo
con se proprio non andare sempre nella
vita nel mezzo alla gente Poi dopo 100
anni entra in un museo abbiamo forse
sbagliato che negli anni 80 90 ci hanno
detto anche il sistema dell'arte di
essere in quel modo Ecco questo non è il
museo d'arte contemporanea Ma questo è
un luogo di quella normalità di quello
ordinario che ogni giorno educa la
bellezza etico attraverso lo stupore la
meraviglia il disturbo e Queste stanze
anche qui realizzate da grandi artisti
Questa è la stanza del Profeta di Pier
Paolo Pasolini poi abbiamo fatto anche
sono 25 camere quindi il museo albergo
restituisce l'agenzia negativa ogni
giorno ha un fruitore di quell'opera di
quell'opera cosiddetta opera d'arte che
ritorna a sentirsi opera e questo è la
bellezza poi l'ultimo impegno questo
tutte le stanze l'ultimo impegno che in
questi giorni sto lavorando e a Catania
e anche qui la coerenza Io mi sono
innamorato di un luogo anzi di un non
luogo a procedere come Purtroppo ci sono
nelle nostre città noi chiamiamo
periferie Ecco le periferie non sono
luoghi da recuperare le verificano
luoghi della devianza della droga dello
spaccio Ecco questa Librino 70 mila
persone 10.000 bambini anche lì Ho
sentito necessità di rigenerare la
bellezza attraverso la condivisione con
tutta la gente del quartiere Questa è
stata la prima opera che la porta della
Bellezza l'abbiamo fatta vent'anni fa il
socio c'è il muro in cemento armato
sotto grazie alla condivisione con
l'arte con gli artisti e soprattutto con
le duemila mamme 2000 bambini dell'epoca
quest'opera sotto ha restituito la
visione della bellezza e tutto il
quartiere e dopo 15 anni è diventato il
simbolo del quartiere di Librino e in
più la gente protegge la bellezza Allora
questo processo artistico Ecco l'opera
d'arte fino a se stessa è sempre anche
di figlia del proprio Ego del proprio
segno del proprio lavoro l'opera d'arte
è in un luogo come Librino come lo Zen
come Scampia è quella di restituire a
tutti gli abitanti anche qui il valore
di sentirsi opera questo processo
artistico quindi è importante nella
creatività non pensare a quello che noi
possiamo realmente creare o si chiamano
scultura pittura
design è importante creare il processo e
il processo youtuber al Librino l'opera
d'arte è il processo Il processo
dell'educazione e della condivisione con
una comunità che grazie a questo impegno
Ecco ha trovato il senso della bellezza
in senso a donare un'opera in un
quartiere periferico dove manca tutto la
strada la fogna Ecco le periferie sono
soltanto serbatoi di voti di un sistema
con l'ignoranza compra 70.000 voti Ecco
non sono luoghi sono luoghi chiusi
regime di sistema E allora Librino
scegliendo la bellezza sceglie quella
visione del futuro che non è costruito
sul recupero e sulla devianza ma sul
riscatto che rigenera bellezza
quest'opera con gli artisti ecco vedete
abbiamo fatto il laboratorio in
terracotta tutti i bambini ora in questi
giorni stanno realizzando tutti questi
manufatti dove attraverso il linguaggio
della
dell'argilla ecco vedete c'è la parte
finale dell'Opera la parte inferiore è
la parte condivisa con i bambini la
parte superiore e la parte creativa
della stessa stesso Ecco ecco vedete qua
ci sono i bambini con i profili Queste
sono un pezzo di argilla di 20 cm
sigilla un patto di bellezza con 2000
bambini con questo profilo che oggi dopo
15 anni Ecco lì l'incontro nella
maturità della vita oggi hanno 30 anni
40 anni e oggi visto che loro sono stati
bravi a rispettare la bellezza e a
proteggerla stiamo realizzando un'ultima
opera
ecco vedete Questa è tutta la parte
della bellezza quella originale Questo è
il librino siamo realizzando la porta
delle farfalle un'opera condivisa con 25
artisti e anche con venti di certistici
di tutta la Sicilia perché anche lì
bisogna
raggiungere questa contemporaneità i
luoghi dell'arte e le agenzie educative
alla bellezza il Calosso Italia catossi
liceo classico e liceo artistico oggi
per ragazzi non può essere una
convenienza pensare e sognare
non serve mentre Oggi più che mai c'è
necessità di sapere c'è necessità di
sogni c'è una dittatura dell'ignoranza
mondiale che vuole attraverso una scuola
messa in discussione perché oggi la
scuola dalle elementari all'università
deve promuovere l'ignoranza non abbiamo
promosso molto conoscenza promuoviamo
ignoranza Perché c'è dittatura di
ignoranza Allora L'arte non serve a
creare un manufatto l'arte serve anche a
risvegliare un po' di coscienza a
consegnare ai bambini che il potere più
grande delle mani è una mano mettere i
libri e una mano mettere i sogni Ecco
questo è il messaggio più tutto quello
che mi sento di portare a Librino anche
con questa realizzazione della porta
delle farfalle perché adesso c'è un
grande muro di un chilometro e mezzo che
stiamo completando in questi giorni e
questa porta delle farfalle è condivisa
con ventimila persone e per questo
condivisione sul Ponte centrale del
quartiere ho scritto in questi giorni un
bellissimo messaggio
etico e anche molto popolare non so se
lo riprendo quello di prima Ecco Questi
sono i pezzi della porta delle farfalle
vedete 20.000 persone stanno
condividendo questo processo artistico
l'opera d'arte sarà il muro trasformato
in bellezza o le 20.000 persone che dopo
quattro generazioni si trovano ancora a
condividere la bellezza al Librino
questo è stato un grande è stata una
grande vittoria politica
dell'Arte della bellezza che anche al
Librino sta fermando un diritto alla
cittadinanza che non passa per recupero
ma passa per la conoscenza nelle
periferie non ci vogliono eserciti di
poliziotti e per riferirci vogliono
esserci gli insegnanti di poeti di
filosofi forse questo abbiamo perso
anche come senso comune di una società
civile che non esiste più Ecco io il
nome di questa coerenza e il nome anche
di questo faretto perché
le utopie che albergavano nei nostri
cuori negli anni 80 utopia non è ciò che
non si può realizzare ma ciò che il
sistema non vuole che si realizzi e
l'artista solo L'artista che straniero
un po' in mezzo a qualunque umanità di
contemporaneità l'artista e si dice
sempre quella visione del futuro
attraverso
azioni e attraverso un cuore che non
trova mai fine nella semina perché lo
spirito che anima la semina
sempre come frutto semina e se uno
semina per tutta la vita raccogliendo la
semina come senso di futuro Ecco Più che
andare con quell'ego che ci accompagna
nella solitudine anche di questa
contemporaneità forse dovremmo imparare
di più ad ascoltare forse dovremmo
imparare di più a ringraziare perché
ringraziare la potenza rivendicare che
purtroppo è figlio del nostro della
nostra egocentricità di questa
contemporaneità quindi trovare il senso
nel ringraziamento ognuno di noi è molto
importante l'arte e che in luoghi come
Librino sta restituendo questa visione a
70 mila persone perché la Librino ci
sono 70 mila persone 10.000 bambini che
grazie a questo processo artistico
stanno trovando quel respiro universale
della Bellezza il coraggio che è stato
un po' questo minimo comune denominatore
di stasera il coraggio è sempre quello
del cuore e quello di non spegnere mai
il cuore Bisogna ringraziare
l'ingratitudine nella vita perché il
genere umano non conosce a
ringraziamento altro ringraziamento
rispondiamo sempre con ingratitudine e
per non fermarci mai E per non farci
fermare mai da qualunque sistema
togliendo l'eco forse dovremmo imparare
a ringraziare l'ingratitudine
Ringraziando l'ingratitudine ci
restituisce quel coraggio fino alla fine
di rimanere coerenti e in uno stato di
Grazia grazie
[Applauso]